[Music]
now it is my pleasure to introduce our
commencement speaker dr. Irwin M Jacobs
his distinguished biography is included
in your programs but dr. Jacobs is one
of mi t--'s most illustrious and
successful graduates whose leadership of
the telecommunications industry his
advocacy of science and math education
and his philanthropy in education in the
arts are inspiring and in the best
tradition of MIT ladies and gentlemen
distinguished guests graduates and
graduates to be dr. Irwin Jacobs thank
you very much it's a great honor to be
here with you on this very special
occasion and I would like to give
special thanks to president Susan
Hockfield for asking me to provide this
address I'd also like to congratulate
the class of 2005 on this very special
day and provide welcome to the family
and friends of the graduates to the
faculty here to the entire MIT family I
really indeed is a very special time
it's a very great day to graduate I
remember back to my receiving my
graduate degrees here our masters and a
doctorate back in 57 and 59 quite a few
years ago fitting very well in with the
50-year reunion class
I must say that at that time I could not
possibly have imagined all the things
that were going to happen in my life
over the succeeding years and that
indeed is something I'd like to pick as
the theme today namely that we are all
going to and in particular you are going
to be going through great deal of change
providing both opportunities and
occasionally some problems but that in
fact an MIT education is about the best
possible way to prepare yourselves for
this very exciting future
I suspect again that a few years from
now and you have the opportunity to
think back then many things that you
just could not have anticipated and so
it's important to be prepared be
prepared for those changes my life
itself has been a number of changes I'll
use those for an example I actually was
born in New Bedford Massachusetts not
too far from here when I graduated high
school I had always been interested in
math and chemistry physics my high
school counselor advised me that there
was and this was 1950 that there was no
future in science nor an engineering and
since I didn't really have a measure to
evaluate that I then took his advice my
family had a small restaurant and so I
entered a School of Hotel administration
at Cornell University well I had an
engineer as roommate after a
year-and-a-half of hearing him talk
about you couldn't possibly get those
grades if you were in engineering and
knowing I really preferred engineering
again I made a very significant change
in life and decided to transfer over to
Electrical Engineering and that was a
very exciting period I was a co-op
student that turned out to be very
useful one of the engineers I worked
with then advised me to go on to
graduate school and that's how I ended
up at MIT but thinking back the one in
my last term at Cornell and this how
fast things have changed I took a course
in the theory and
building of vacuum tubes built a 6 SN 7
to 6 j6 you probably never even heard of
these terms any longer I was reminded
that all last week when I gave a talk at
the computer Museum in Mountain View
and that in fact has a lot of equipment
that originally came from a computer
Museum here in Boston but now it's out
in Mountain View California and so as we
toured around looking at all the
equipment seeing analog and digital
differential analyzer ZUP to cell phones
which of course are the latest and most
powerful computers I'll come back to
that that it was amazing to me how fast
things have changed and again that's the
key issue with change it with amazing to
see all these familiar items that had
been in my life and then passed out of
it so quickly
well I decide to apply and luckily was
accepted here at MIT to graduate school
originally came thinking that e/m theory
electromagnetic theory would be an
interesting area but MIT at that time
professor Claude Shannon had just come
father of information theory there was a
lot of interest in the theory the
mathematics probability theory etc and
so I decided that that would be my
future and very pleased with that
decision
one of the early courses I took was from
professor Norbert Wiener now I don't
think probably anyone here might have
had the opportunity but it was very
interesting there are many tales I'm
sure still running around MIT about
professor Wiener are one that I most
remember and taking this class probably
like several of the classes you might
have taken the elections were well I
shouldn't say that's probably it's not
the case anymore but the lectures were
incomprehensible and so each night a
group of graduate students would get
together and try to figure out what it
was we had heard during the day and kind
of put it together in a way that we
could understand about half way through
the term for us Wiener heard that we
were doing this
came to the room and said can I look at
the material became interested said we
should make a book from this and so we
then continued to put the material
together as a book he would come in
every day after class and his only
question was how many pages are we up to
so he always had a different slant on
things that book did come out its
nonlinear problems and random theories
that was the first book that I was ever
involved with went on the faculty here
again it's a wonderful way of some of
you are considering careers and teaching
I'd greatly recommend it it's the best
way to learn material and while here
decided with Professor Jack Rosen craft
to put together a book a textbook for a
senior level communications course on
applying what was then brand-new digital
theory and information theory I tried to
give it a little bit more of a practical
face and there were many at the time
that said that there really is no
practical use for this if she just
treated as applied mathematics in fact
of course that's turned out not to be
the case at all
I did take a leave of absence to make my
one visit to California about the time
we're finishing the book in 64 65
we decided that might be a good place to
retire some time came back to Boston had
a call from a professor from Cornell
thing he's going out to start a brand
new uniform Stata Department of
Electrical Engineering a brand new
University in San Diego would we join
him first reaction of course was no
family friends career here but after a
couple of days we decided that
California and a brand new university an
opportunity for a different experience
might be quite exciting in our lives and
we accepted again change to change from
here to a brand new school it was
interesting in a brand new school is
very small of course very few faculty
one of the classes I started had to do
with introduction to computer science
there were some engineering students but
there were students from math
and faculty from from music and from the
arts departments and kind of an
interacting with them developed even a
greater love and appreciation for the
Arts and for music that we've been able
to follow than ever since it was very
interesting being in a brand-new
University but that also led to another
major change in my life because of the
MIT background a lot of in it of
industry in Southern California there
were many requests for consulting
typically if you're in the faculty you
might consult a day a week and so I
mentioned that to a couple of friends
from UCLA and the fact that the UCLA as
we were flying back on a trip and they
said let's start a company and share
consulting and I said fine as long as I
don't have to get involved with managing
it and so we started a first company
called link Abed and very quickly it
began to grow and so I did then decide
to take a year off and check out
business try to get things properly
organized didn't know really a thing
about it luckily in the hotel school I
had a course in accounting course and
business Florence a little bit of
background turned out to be very useful
but really had to were in the business
side of things engineering is by far the
best preparation for just about any
field so that has indeed worked out very
well
well wink a bit this first company did
grow very nicely we got involved in a
number of interesting programs one
scrambling TV signals from satellite to
home that's turned into a very major
business another what to called very
small aperture earth terminals for if
you put a credit card in at a gas
station often it will go over one of
these satellite terminals the first
what's called time division TDM a type
of cellular phone we got into the cell
phone business early on and actually a
processor we didn't know the name of the
time I don't think was really out but a
reduced instruction set processor RISC
processor that we built into a terminal
for use in government programs in a
particular for a program here at Lincoln
Laboratory to communicate with what was
then
the less 8/9 satellite so again things
tied back together very nicely but very
exciting to be able to come up with
ideas be able to apply theory to things
that were rather practical rather useful
well we made the mistake in a sense of
selling that company and in 1985 our
retired
retirement was a terrible thing
so I lasted about three months and then
started Qualcomm and I very much assured
my wife that if things went very well we
might have a hundred employees at some
time put that in contacts we're now over
8,000 employees and by the way am I
welcoming I also meant to welcome any
Qualcomm shareholders that might be here
today well we didn't have any products
luckily we didn't have to go out for
venture capital so we didn't have to
have a business plan but we knew digital
we knew Wireless would be very exciting
and it turned out that it was on a drive
down from me a consulting contract
meeting in Los Angeles that drive down
to San Diego about halfway luckily it's
110 miles or so but halfway down
realized that something called code
division multiple access CDMA would be
very useful for mobile communications
well the company was very small we had
to wait a few years before we could go
ahead and develop that idea but the time
came when we sold our first product had
a little bit of a cash flow and we're
able to then go back and pay attention
to CDMA actually at the end of 1988
began to take a look at it well if any
of you decide to go into your own
businesses and some of you I'm sure will
be doing that you run across a time when
you have to make a bet the company
decision and so CDMA was one of those
should you put a lot of money into R&D
in a technology that may or may not be
accepted the world was going off in a
different direction
and luckily at that time I had not heard
one of the projections
that had been made to 18t by a
consultant two years earlier or a few
years earlier that if all went well
there might be a million cell phones in
use by the year 2000 actually they
missed by a little bit it was 600
million and that of course gave a great
opportunity for moving ahead with CDMA
we did develop the technology
demonstrated because otherwise
everything sounds too complicated you
have to have demonstrations so that was
again one of the bet your company type
issues and then the question comes up if
you now have good product how do you
build a business model what do you do
about that and so again this is a type
of concern that you may be having going
forward we decided to go into a mode
which was both licensing and of selling
initially phones and infrastructure get
things started but ultimately the chips
and that works out very well as you know
chips keep getting more more powerful
you can put more and more capability in
them if you come up with innovative
ideas you can build those into the chips
and so that's exactly the path that we
followed it's interesting that today
there's probably about one and a half
billion uses of cell phones around the
world in 2005 there were over 600
million sold in the one year or will be
by the end of the year comparing that to
about a hundred and fifty million
desktop and laptop computers it's quite
clear that the future is not in plastics
but really now in mobile devices and the
interesting aspect is that the
capabilities keep going up one of the
things that is now being provided as
what's called third-generation I won't
again go into details but if some of you
have been using not just the wireless
that's available on campus that's called
802 11 but a wide area coverage provided
right now by Verizon here going to get a
very high data rate anywhere that you
can receive a cell phone call and so
that is a key step but the interesting
part is the devices and
because of Moore's Law the number
transistors on a chip doubling roughly
every two years or so power going down
costs going down all the right things
kind of happening there's been a major
transformation when we first built I
built the first cell phone
it took three chips to implement the
communications only now it takes about
20% of one chip what do you do with the
other 80% you can put a lot of computing
power in fact now we're going to two
processes one of which is moving toward
a gigahertz type processing speed to
processes a couple of signal processing
units a 3d graphics capability GPS
receiving you can put a watt on that
chip make it available at a low cost
high reliability and therefore very
useful to people therefore since it's a
computer now not really a phone you may
not realize that when you're carrying it
around very powerful computer that opens
up many possibilities and so we
developed a another approach we call GRU
in fact there's a conference now with
about 2,400 people at it occurring in
San Diego where developers anywhere in
the world can develop an application to
be downloaded to the phone we arranged
to provide a digital signature tested
digital signature so it won't get
corrupt the phone and therefore they can
develop these bring them via some
internet meeting grounds we've
established with the operators bring
their applications the attention of
operators around the world and build a
business and I think at this last at
this meeting that's ongoing was
mentioned that there was about 350
million dollars that had the funnel from
operators to Qualcomm and then Qualcomm
back to the developers around the world
and this last six months in the art of
150 million so it's providing a very
interesting base for people to start new
companies be able to market relatively
and expensively have a very large market
the more exciting aspect is other things
I think that we're going to be able to
do with that we've all heard of issues
with the digital divide access to
communications to the end
that being more limited in certain
regions I think that the phone is a
low-cost device with a huge amount of
computing power a connection to the
Internet ability to download software
process that large amount of memory by
the way can be used with the appropriate
amount of thinking and planning and be
used to supplement teaching in many
remote areas as well as of course
developed areas around the world so I
think that there's a great possibility
there to move ahead with these devices
people so just realizing what the power
in the devices might be and again
hopefully some of you out there will
find this of challenging of course
there's also medical devices that are
now being attached to the cell phone
measuring blood capabilities and moving
toward eager meant providing support
voting information etc by use of the
cell phone so again a device we think of
as a phone very powerful computer
opening lots of opportunities well I
mentioned ego Vermin t' one of the
things i would like to recommend to all
of you early some of you is to think
well all of you to think about politics
to some of you perhaps to consider a
career in politics again think an MIT
education prepares you for just about
anything and was interesting I was over
a couple of years ago so it's the
previous president of China we had a
meeting they always have this very
formal you so you and the president
myself and the president was sitting at
the head of the you and then staffs on
either side and there's a little bit of
chitchat that occurs before the formal
meeting what do you think the first
question that was raised by the
president of China sitting next to me
how many more generations that I think
North War had to run president of China
discussing with him little further it
turned out he actually was trained as an
engineer as a radio engineer as was the
prime minister at the time that's the
kind of interest and ability to again
think about technology bring it to use
that I think is also very important here
in this country and of course there's
very little of that available here
another aspect when I came to the
student here I was lucky to benefit from
the research laboratory of electronics
but it was very well funded at the time
now the funding has been cut back quite
a bit
there really are reasons to get out to
become very politically active well
there have been many rewards from having
this type of an education being able to
go out the world is changing one can
take advantage those changes do very
well it's important of course to have an
impact back and the opportunity for for
philanthropy of course never goes away
we've been very lucky focus often is on
education but also cultural activities
other activities around the world and I
think again that's something that as you
begin to move ahead in your careers that
you should definitely pay attention to
so I'd like to finish by again
congratulating you you're embarking on a
great adventure you're probably entering
a period where there's even greater
change greater things happening around
the world then was correct when I
graduated here you might have seen the
statement back from that 1899 that the
head of the Patent Office said that
everything that can be invented has been
invented clearly another short-sighted
statement but if you check with the
Patent Office now you'll find that many
of the applications many of the patents
in the US Patent Office are coming from
overseas and so again the competition is
heightened we have to move ahead we have
to improve our education throughout we
have to remain very innovative you can
certainly be guaranteed that there will
be there changes you have been well
prepared I wish you as much fun and
excitement as I have had along the way
thank you all very much
[Applause]